his extradition case has rolled through
the courts for months
this man calls himself arthur knight
glasgow based and married to miranda
u.s authorities say he is in fact
nicholas rossi and they want him
extradited to stand trial the
prosecution narrative is that you are
an alleged rapist
there are restraining orders
assaults
fraud
and a very
colorful criminal record that reflects a
dangerous
sexual predator
are you that man are you nicholas rossi
i can veritably say that i have not
ever once done any of the acts as you
just described
despite his denials america wants to
extradite a man they say has more than a
dozen aliases he's accused of faking his
own death complete with a hoax obituary
and a call to a priest posing as the
grieving widow
she sounded like hyacinth bouquet you
know a very
high-pitched english woman's accent
father bernard healey agreed to a
request to hold a memorial mass until
the police stepped in the detective said
to me
he thought it was nicholas using a voice
disguiser
an international manhunt took police to
this hospital last december the man
calling himself arthur knight had caught
covet
while he lay on a ventilator officers
were alerted to tattoos on his body a
court would later be told that
fingerprints showed a match to nicholas
rossi
these are images of the wanted man in
america a campaigner for child welfare
reform who once posed for a photo with
former vice president mike pence how do
these images compare to the man facing
extradition
could you take your glasses off would
you lie
and are you able to take off your mask
do you see a similarity
do you
the eyebrows are the same
i'm sorry
i don't know what i could do about my
eyebrows
the man we interviewed has a small scar
to the side of his right eye
images on the interpol red notice show a
man with a scar in a similar place
in his glasgow flat we asked about the
similarity
you have a scar in the same place can
you explain that
no i can't
and either they're
photoshopped
oh
everyone every police image
i'm not entirely cert but those are all
authentic police images
the same interpol notice shows tattoos
on both arms in glasgow we were shown
forearms but couldn't see any body art
that didn't convince brian coogan a
former state representative in rhode
island who knew the man wanted by police
for more than 20 years we brought the
man in glasgow together with a man in
massachusetts in
he's calling you nick this is a man who
knew nicholas rossi for 21 years
this is a man he's also been all over
the news
he seems to enjoy it
look at his two biceps he has a barcode
on one and a bird feather on the other
our wing
is he willing to show you his arms
are you would you is that something you
would do would you shoot your arms i've
shown you
your biceps yeah i wish
okay i am not getting in this
conversation
the man calling himself author knight
married his wife using the name nicholas
brown two and a half years ago miranda
has stood by him throughout the police
pursuit
they would have it that you yourself are
a victim
of a con man and a criminal
what do you say to that
from my point of view
i have felt the safest i have ever felt
my husband with alpha
i
there has never been
any
um
type of abuse
i
he shows love he shows patience
i never feel unsafe
is the game up for you the game has just
started the game is afoot
earlier this week he was convicted of
abusing staff in a glasgow hospital
since we interviewed him he's been
remanded in custody an extradition court
will decide when that ends and where
james matthews sky news edinburgh